watching football in Brazil is one of
the most intense sensory experiences in
all sports but what if you're a football
fan and you suffer from autism for those
diagnosed with the condition which
includes social and language
difficulties as well as repetitive
Behavior watching a match can be a
traumatic experience it prompted this
man to set up a group to help those
supporters with the conditions
our soccer fan group came from
Corinthians we always watched the games
a late diagnosis of autism and decide to
create this movement joining Corinthians
and autism
some of the measures include a sensory
room complete with noise-proof glass
walls special lighting and crayons
spread on multiple tables with toys and
food it's all designed to have a carving
effect
the pioneering work of the Sao Paulo
Bass Club has led to 31 year old autism
Safra Luis booty being hired by
Corinthians as a stadium guide
when I got here to work no one talked
about autism it wasn't something mean to
exclude us it just wasn't a big topic
for our society it was a bubble and
thank God that bubble has burst and now
this is a topic for everyone
according to the country's Health
ministry as many as 10 million people
are on the autism spectrum in Brazil the
work of autistas Alvin Negros playing a
vital role in ensuring that everyone
here in soccer mad Sao Paulo has a
chance to enjoy the beautiful game
Al Jazeera